-Txetx, ça va ?
-Ouais, ça va.
-Merci de nous accueillir
dans le Petit Bayonne,
pour parler de notre combat commun,
l'accès au logement pour tous.
-Là, entre 2015 et 2020,
il y a des dizaines de logements,
rien qu'ici,
qui sont devenus des Airbnb.
Donc, permanents !
Ce troisième étage,
il y avait un couple
de jeunes travailleurs
qui payaient un loyer
de 500 euros, comme ça,
la propriétaire les a fait dégager
et a transformé ça en Airbnb,
qui se louait, du coup,
autour de 100 euros la nuit.
-Bonjour. Inaki Echaniz,
député des Pyrénées-Atlantiques.
*On est à Bayonne
pour parler de la crise du logement
qui frappe ce territoire,
comme d'autres en France,
du fait de la spéculation,
de la montée des taux d'intérêt,
de la multiplication
des meublés de tourisme,
et avec de vraies difficultés
*pour les habitants
de se loger là où ils travaillent.
Nous devons agir pour que chacun
puisse trouver un toit.
-Sur la côte basque,
au début de l'automne,
les vacanciers sont partis.
Il reste ceux qui vivent ici
toute l'année.
Dans cette région touristique
où l'économie est florissante,
les habitants ont
de plus en plus de mal à se loger.
Le député socialiste Inaki Echaniz
retrouve, cette fois à Biarritz,
Txetx Etcheverry,
le fondateur de l'association Alda,
qui aide
les locataires en difficulté.
-Alors, qu'est-ce qui se passe ici ?
-On va aller visiter
M. Fabrice Dupont,
qui est locataire depuis 20 ans ici.
Il a eu un congé pour vente.
Il doit dégager.
-Allez, on y va.
-Plusieurs fois par mois,
Alda est sollicitée
par des habitants
menacés d'expulsion.
-Bonjour. Merci de nous recevoir.
-Bonjour. Enchanté.
-A 60 ans, Fabrice doit se préparer
à quitter son quartier.
-Il doit partir vite...
-Si vous pouviez nous expliquer
ce qui se passe ?
-Ce qui se passe,
c'est que ça fait 18 ans
que je vis dans ce studio,
et j'ai appris en juin 2022
que ma propriétaire
a décidé de vendre.
-Vous savez vous reloger ?
-Actuellement, non.
-Les loyers sont trop chers ?
-J'ai 1045 euros de revenus.
90 euros d'allocation logement.
Je paye 430 euros, là.
Voilà.
-C'est impossible
de retrouver au même prix ?
-Impossible.
-Vous avez fait une demande
de logement social ?
-J'ai fait une demande en...
Ben en juin 2022, hein.
-Ouais, tout de suite.
-Je suis passé en commission
en novembre 2022.
Bon, j'étais...
J'ai pas été retenu.
-Ce n'est pas acceptable
que quelqu'un puisse être sorti
de son logement,
sans raison valable,
et qu'on ne lui propose pas
d'autres solutions.
Il y aurait
assez de logements sociaux,
il y aurait un parc privé
avec des prix abordables,
on pourrait l'entendre,
mais aujourd'hui,
ce n'est plus acceptable
de faire de la spéculation.
La propriétaire va le vendre
plus cher en le vendant vide.
-Tous craignent surtout
que ce studio ne devienne
un appartement touristique.
-Il suffit de voir mon agence.
Sur vitrine, ce n'est
que des locations de vacances.
Il y a quelques mois,
ils avaient une annonce à l'année.
Sur l'étage,
je suis tout seul à l'année.
Résidence secondaire,
résidence secondaire, Airbnb.
-Petit à petit,
nos villes sont grignotées.
Ici, à Biarritz, il y a plus
de logements que d'habitants,
mais personne n'arrive à se loger.
-Au Pays basque, l'histoire
de Fabrice est loin d'être isolée.
Avec l'arrivée des plates-formes
de location en ligne,
il y a de moins en moins
de logements pour les locaux.
Ce phénomène a changé la physionomie
du quartier historique de Bayonne.
-Ca, c'est le drapeau que mettent
de plus en plus d'habitants
pour demander le droit
à se loger au pays.
-Il y a quelques mois,
dans cette zone,
Txetx Etcheverry et son association
ont squatté un appartement
loué via Airbnb pour dénoncer
la spéculation.
Le député,
bien conscient du problème,
voit monter l'exaspération
des habitants.
-Je crois que le message est clair.
-Ouais.
-Cette immense fresque a été peinte
par un collectif d'associations
qui viennent d'obtenir
une première victoire :
les villes de la côte basque
imposent désormais
un système de compensation :
chaque propriétaire
qui met en location
un appartement de tourisme
doit obligatoirement
en mettre un second
en location à l'année.
Cette nouvelle réglementation
est très contraignante,
mais il est trop tôt
pour savoir si elle enraye vraiment
la spéculation.
Favorable à ce système,
le député sait aussi
qu'il n'y a pas de mesure magique.
Le socialiste
a rédigé une proposition de loi
avec des collègues Renaissance
pour défendre
d'autres solutions.
-La première des choses,
c'est de revoir
la fiscalité.
Quelqu'un qui loue
en meublé de tourisme a
71 % d'abattement
sur ses revenus,
alors que quelqu'un qui loue
en longue durée, il a 30 %.
On propose de, a minima, remettre
à égalité les taux d'imposition,
et de les baisser à 30 %,
si ce n'est d'augmenter
l'abattement fiscal
sur la longue durée
pour encourager les propriétaires.
On est dans une telle crise
qu'il faut faire revenir du logement
sur la longue durée.
-En juin 2023,
sa proposition de loi transpartisane
a été déprogrammée
de l'agenda
de l'Assemblée nationale
à la dernière minute,
car le gouvernement
n'en voulait pas.
Les plates-formes non plus.
A cause de la pénurie
de logements,
la tension est vive
entre une partie des habitants
et des élus,
et, de l'autre, les propriétaires
des meublés de tourisme.
Le nouveau système
de compensation accentue encore
le conflit.
Une association de propriétaires
se bat juridiquement
pour le faire annuler.
Carla en fait partie.
En colère, elle ne veut pas
rencontrer le député.
Elle accepte de nous parler,
à condition
de rester anonyme.
Voix modifiée
-On a peur.
Peut-être que j'exagère,
mais on a peur de représailles.
Vous avez vu ce qu'il s'est passé
sur beaucoup d'agences immobilières.
Il y a des tags.
Demain, ce sera des bombes.
On voudrait pas retrouver
notre appartement tagué
ou squatté ou... Voilà.
-Carla vit dans l'intérieur
du Pays basque.
En 2015, elle a acheté
ce deux-pièces près de l'océan
qu'elle loue 5 mois par an
via les plates-formes.
Avec les nouvelles règles
qui s'appliquent aussi
aux actuels propriétaires,
elle ne pourra plus le faire.
-On a économisé pour avoir tout ça,
on s'est sacrifiés,
et maintenant qu'on est bien,
on a l'impression d'avoir pris
une claque dans la figure.
Franchement,
on ne pensait à aucun moment
qu'on allait nous interdire
de faire ce que l'on veut
de notre résidence secondaire,
sachant qu'on ne la mettra pas
en vente,
et qu'on ne fera pas
de location à l'année.
On nous prive de notre liberté
de choix sur cet appartement.
On voudrait pas être
les boucs émissaires
du manque de logements.
On comprend pas
pourquoi les communes
n'ont pas fait le nécessaire
depuis 20 ans,
à faire de la construction.
-Loin de l'Atlantique,
dans l'intérieur des terres,
le manque de logements
est aussi un problème,
même dans les zones
les plus reculées du Béarn.
Dans la circonscription du député,
la vallée d'Aspe
a longtemps perdu des habitants.
Désormais, elle en gagne.
Pour les nouveaux arrivants,
se loger relève
du parcours du combattant.
Nous retrouvons Inaki Echaniz,
qui rend visite à Grégory.
Depuis des mois,
ce quinquagénaire vit dans un gîte.
-Voilà.
On met tout là en attendant.
-Vous stockez votre vie ?
-C'est un peu ça.
On a tous nos meubles,
nos souvenirs,
nos tableaux, nos photos...
-Ce qui devait être temporaire,
ça dure...
-Ca fait une petite année.
-A l'étage, la décoration est figée
dans les années 70.
Grégory et sa famille
n'ont rien touché,
juste ajouté quelques photos,
pour personnaliser l'endroit.
Ils veulent acheter
leur propre maison,
mais il n'y a quasiment rien
à vendre,
et les prix sont exorbitants.
-Où est-ce que vous en êtes ?
-On a déjà eu deux échecs.
Un parce que ça a été vendu
pour une résidence secondaire,
ce qui est dommage,
et un autre parce qu'on est
dans une région où c'est protégé,
et on peut pas
rénover les maisons.
Ca fait 12 ans qu'on vient ici,
et je suis parapentiste.
C'est le bon lieu.
J'ai racheté une société
dans le parapente.
C'est important
d'être établi ici.
Il y a des prix
qui sont comme à Bordeaux.
-Sur la vallée d'Aspe,
on a quantifié
une augmentation de 30 à 40 %
du prix au m2 depuis le Covid.
-Et encore, nous,
on a une situation...
On a vendu notre maison,
donc on a un pécule,
les banques vont nous suivre.
Je me mets à la place des jeunes...
Ca doit être dur.
-Aujourd'hui, on a des enfants
de la vallée, de mon âge,
qui ne peuvent pas venir ici.
C'est un déchirement.
C'est pas du communautarisme,
mais on vient d'un territoire
dans lequel on ne peut plus habiter.
-Une bonne fin de journée à vous.
-Merci. Au revoir !
-Comme sur le littoral,
le problème viendrait
des résidences secondaires
qui font concurrence
aux logements permanents.
A 8 kilomètres du gîte,
le village d'Accous,
dans lequel Grégory et sa famille
voudraient poser définitivement
leurs valises.
Inaki Echaniz a rendez-vous
avec le maire
pour une visite guidée.
-On va faire un petit tour
dans le village.
-Ouais, ça marche.
-On y va.
Oui, donc, notre problème à nous,
c'est les résidences secondaires.
C'est 50 % de la commune.
-A l'image de la vallée.
-Oui.
Résidence secondaire.
Résidence familiale.
Ca aussi,
c'est une résidence secondaire.
Ca aussi.
Ca aussi, après.
-Pour le maire d'Accous,
trouver des maisons
pour ceux qui veulent vivre ici
est un combat quotidien,
et il n'hésite pas,
s'il le faut,
à faire l'intermédiaire.
-Par exemple, ces deux maisons
que tu vois, ici, là,
ici et derrière,
sont devenues
des résidences principales
depuis quelques mois,
parce qu'on a négocié
de manière à ce qu'ils fassent
des prix raisonnables,
et on a fixé deux familles
en résidence principale.
-Combien d'habitants à l'année ?
-470.
-Et l'été ?
-On doit monter à un millier,
avec les maisons ouvertes,
les campings.
On doit monter à un millier.
-Pour juguler les prix,
le député socialiste
veut changer la loi,
et là encore,
son levier,
ce sont les impôts.
-Notre volonté,
c'est de donner
des outils pratiques aux communes,
notamment aux petites communes,
pour pouvoir agir en faveur
de l'habitat permanent.
-Un exemple ?
-Concrètement,
on va taxer de façon plus forte
quelqu'un qui achète
une résidence secondaire
pour 2 ans, dans l'état d'esprit
de faire une plus-value,
de faire un coup de peinture
ou de creuser une piscine,
et qui va la vendre
100 000 euros de plus,
2 ou 3 ans plus tard.
-Le maire tient aussi
à montrer au député
une des maisons à vendre
dans le village.
-On arrive devant une belle maison,
une ancienne maison familiale,
qui est en vente.
Il y a 300 mètres carrés
de surface habitable,
avec un grand jardin,
et il y aurait la possibilité
de faire 3 logements dedans.
Elle est à vendre à 130 000 euros,
mais c'est un prix négociable.
Il y en a au moins
pour 300 000 euros
de travaux à faire, minimum,
si on veut faire
3 appartements indépendants.
On a un droit de préemption.
Si je sentais
que cette maison partait
en résidence secondaire
ou en Airbnb,
j'aurais la possibilité
de me porter acquéreur,
à 120 000 euros,
mais nous, communes,
on n'aura pas les moyens, derrière,
d'investir 300 000
ou 400 000 euros
pour faire des appartements.
-Les maires peuvent augmenter
la taxe d'habitation
sur les résidences secondaires.
Le député voudrait
en relever le plafond.
-Ca ne les poussera pas
à revendre leurs biens
ou à les mettre
à la location longue durée,
mais ça les fera participer
à l'effort général
et ça permettra
à la collectivité
de ramasser cet argent
et de le réinvestir
dans des projets
à vocation de longue durée,
comme c'est le cas ici.
-Un combat au long cours
pour Inaki Echaniz,
alors que la crise du logement
s'accentue.
Il ne désespère pas
d'arriver à convaincre
les autres députés
et le gouvernement
d'adopter ses propositions.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...